we're going to Australia Tuesday and we
left at 9 p.m. Sunday made it to my
hotel room in Adelaide Adelaide is our
first stop on the snow filter tour this
is the room room tour Wow Wow Wow in
case you didn't believe me that I'm in
Adelaide right now so University of
Adelaide and what a view Australia oh my
god also an airport when we landed I got
my first flat white which wasn't just my
nickname in high school it's what you
Australians call coffee and it's Shing
delicious how how do you make your
coffee so good and your Wi-Fi so bad
Australia they're so quirky
[Music]
stay tuned in Adelaide we are rehearsing
for the show tomorrow
yeah we're fueling up yeah because we're
working on choreography which really
takes a lot out of all of us I stood for
1000 there's not gonna do oh my god
panic everyone panic we're fine
hello guys it is the morning no it is
the afternoon definitely it is almost
1:00 p.m. it is the afternoon before our
first nofilter show in Australia in
Adelaide last night our promoter and our
tour manager Brad and Simon took Hannah
mamrie and I out to get African food
which was delicious and now we are
getting ready for the show
I am out of breath I'm turning the
camera on which is great because I'm
about to go to the gym to get some
pre-show stress out of my body here's a
gym outfit of the day
this black t-shirt and wow wow Who am I
I just Dean I seriously love what you
were I just dude these are from Target
whoa and then Hannah Mayer coming here
we're rehearsing and then we're going to
the venue and we're starting the tour
uh-huh we're here at the first show in
Adelaide look at this audience
Wow lively look at his hair also lively
everyone's getting ready
maimry is bearing the brunt of all of
the tech which is very stressful right
now it's always happens it never runs
completely smooth there's always
something that is an issue yeah through
the side of my head we're going to our
first meet and greet in Adelaide
[Music]
oh my god
they're so polite we just finished
showing Adelaide dad it was our stepdad
Lily I know he was your step down on
your tour but Simon is now the tour
manager for us on our tour so he's now
our stepdad that's rough yeah and hannah
has never had a passion fruit before
I've had lots of passion this is the
first time it comes in fruitful put that
in the block good morning we are off to
Melbourne sorry
I'm in my own universe right now but
this is what we travel with every
traveller crash it's uh promoters like
Simon a tour manager
two functional dumb 3x luggage hey we
just landed in Melbourne wood we were on
the bus right now yeah everybody's
having a great time not seeing me
okay we just been that that our tour
manager Simon's Instagram is shrimp is
get spelled like limp bizkit 7-6 to that
correct if you guys love Connor Franta
Instagram joint seen nothing yet do you
did that trip biscuit 760 this is
happening or just have I'm very
inquisitive enough yeah heart ooh that
is Wow Wow no we did okay
we are headed to Z
[Music]
I'm back in my room after the Melbourne
shell it was an amazing show you guys
are so great and sweet show number two
of five and I had a great time I hope
all of you that came to the show had a
great time thank you for laughing and
sweating and laughing just ordered room
service gonna wait for that tomorrow
morning we wake up and we go to Sydney
to do the show in Sydney wow this is a
whirlwind of a tour we've never done it
this way where we fly perform fly
perform fly perform I've already
gathered a very thick layer of scum and
wet person so I should clean that at
some point tonight oh this is where
fried area ends for now it will pick up
for next week in the next Friday re um
oh yeah I also I instagrammed my travel
outfit of the day I've been doing a lot
of outfit of the days lately in
conjunction with my style book which is
coming out on February 2nd which you can
pre-order at great style book calm other
than that I am a start like huh I don't
know hi what did you know Lily Lily oh
my god what's your name ah